hey what's up good folks this is dr john
delany with ramsey network
today we are talking about social
anxiety
got an email here we go
hi dr john what's up i have loved your
anxiety videos and wanted to ask you a
specific question
thank you i appreciate it i don't want
to sound tone deaf by saying covet has
been a good thing for me but the
shutdown cancelled
all social events that would ordinarily
cause me to have breakdowns and anxiety
attacks
it has been the most peaceful time of my
life even though i have been home with
six children because i haven't had to
see anyone except my family
last week sports reopened for our oldest
three children
i quickly started to feel tightness in
my chest and shoulders and i'm on edge
like never before
i'm scared to death of people and their
opinions will the other moms like me
will they think i'm too fat do they
notice that i always have my hair in a
messy bun
because i don't know how to do anything
else with it does she know my childhood
rapist and is she going to tell them
where i
am is the babies fussing annoying them
do they remember my family's history
here
and think i'm the same as the others
does she think i'm worthless for not
having a job and on and on
do you have any suggestions for anxiety
related to a person's own lack of
self-confidence and self-worth
and for dealing with anxiety attacks
that come from social interactions
susan thank you so much for your email
this is a lot
and i'm going to dig in here we go first
let's just define social anxiety right
it's a phobia or a fear of social
interactions
when you get around people when you get
around unfamiliar situations
your anxiety alarms go off and if you've
had trauma in your past
they go off loud for those of you who
don't have a social phobia you think
social anxiety is stupid it's not even
real so lame dude get over it
imagine yourself in a dark alley you
turn a corner
and there's three dudes with guns and
another dude with a knife and they start
running at you
how you would freeze your heart would
start racing your pupils dilate
and you go into full fight or flight
mode
or freeze mode that's social anxiety
when somebody goes to a grocery store
that's social anxiety when somebody
walks into church that's social anxiety
when somebody shows up to a little
league game
and they just want to support their kid
but every alarm system they have is
going off internally
and it just makes it hard to breathe
the author of this email susan she's
asking exposure questions
are people going to actually know me are
they going to see me
are they going to be judging the way i
look are they going to be judging my
inadequacies are they going to be
judging my blessings
the answer susan is no most people most
of the time
don't care about you you know why
because they're busy with their own
insecurities
they're worried about other people
watching them or some people are just
blessed and they simply don't care other
people think about them
what a gift that would be right some
people work really hard to get to that
place
or they had great parents great
community great social circles
that have built them up have given them
internal self-confidence they love
themselves
and they just radiate joy to other
people they don't really care what
people think about them
but most people most of the time are
worried how they present themselves to
the world
to other people know that my kids
sporting goods gear is used
the people know that my kid's not the
best player on the team and it's kind of
embarrassing
or that i didn't get to brush my teeth
today before i can't whatever people are
usually thinking about themselves
thinking about other people thinking
about them right
it's this toxic hurricane that we all
live in
so susan the answer really it's probably
not
and if people do notice wow she's more
overweight than we are
or her hair is messier than yours is who
cares
who cares you know why they don't get a
vote
they don't get a vote you're raising six
kids you have six kids the fact that
you're upright and breathing and they're
all fed
is more than most people will do in a
given day most
people cannot do what you do and that
leads me to number two
really the most revealing part of this
email
you mention a childhood rapist for me
that is stop the presses
that is park it right there we're not
going forward
until you have some coping mechanisms
for dealing with childhood trauma
severe childhood trauma that's a park it
until you've got
a community that's going to walk
alongside you until you've got some
uh support exercises some ways of being
to silence the alarms
because if you have severe childhood
trauma like childhood physical abuse or
sexual abuse childhood rape
social situations are ghastly
that part of your brain that is always
skinning the environment for future pain
for future hurt for future trauma
every time you get around strangers
every time you get around other people
that alarm's going off that alarm will
go off and go off and go off
you also discuss a family history here
that you don't want other people to know
about
maybe you've got family members in your
past maybe you've got family members who
left a poor legacy for you that you're
having to
live into as a member of the same
community that they lived in
again trauma can become legacy based
until you turn
with the right support and face it so a
link between
childhood adversity childhood trauma
childhood abuse and social anxiety
that link is clear as can be your brain
is on high alert
and it is always scanning the
environment for who's going to hurt me
next
so the real question susan you've got to
ask yourself is this
do you want to get to a place where you
can go out
do you want to go to these baseball
games and these church events
and the neighborhood grocery store
peaceful
light and fully engaged
and if you don't that's okay that's a
decision you're gonna make
right but if you do i want you know
there's healing on the other side of it
but the first thing you have to do is
make that decision
first thing you do have to answer that
question for yourself
right in your email you say this has
been the greatest few months of your
life
ask yourself do you want to be a person
who thrives in public
if you do if you want to be a person who
will
be out in public with her six kids that
will go to little league games and dance
recitals and 4-h events
or graduations and college send-offs
if you want to be that mom you will have
to invest
deeply in trauma-based trauma-focused
therapy
and that can look like emdr that can
look like brain spotting
that can look like tfc bt trauma focus
cognitive behavioral therapy
that looks like getting with someone who
is going to walk alongside you
teach you skills on how to silence the
alarms
skills on how to exhale when you feel
them coming up
go back through your trauma narrative
and teach you how to be safe moving
forward
susan if you want to be free from this
trauma
from this pain healing's out there it
truly is
my hope is my deepest hope and prayer
for you susan
is that you decide this past trauma
this social anxiety this weight that
sits on me all the time
i don't want that to be my identity
anymore
i want to walk towards peace
if you do healing's there there is a
counselor that will walk alongside you
and help you grow and heal from the
inside out
i want you to be whole and healed and no
longer looking around
for your childhood abuser a present
whole and joy-filled
mom for your six beautiful kids
they deserve that but more importantly
susan
you deserve that because you are worthy
of being
loved you are worthy of peace you are
worthy of a deep
good night sleep
you are worthy of going to your kid's
baseball game and cheering like a crazy
mama
and i hope you'll get that healing i
believe in you and i know you can do
this
this has been dr john dolone for ramsey
network if you know of somebody who's
dealing with social anxiety disorder
if you know somebody who's had childhood
abuse send them this video
don't forget to subscribe follow me at
johndaloni
and if you want to be on the dr john
deloney show
the live call-in show i want to hear
from you
email me at askjohn ramseysolutions.com
leave your cell number
a brief description of your question and
somebody from ramsey network will reach
out to you
and get a schedule to talk together i
can't wait take care